[Music]
talk to me about being here and why it's
so special well first it's a really fun
day where we all get to dress up right
like that was a high extrovert it
doesn't taste very good
it's all super really good oh I'll know
for the good foundation yeah so for very
good cause no pun intended so we hope to
have some fun yeah how long did this
take you and did you do it honestly it
took forever and it took a lot of
patience so I don't know that I'll be
doing it again I was like for real I
don't know how people said it sit down
for prosthetics but then this guy was
very patient for his Dracula makeup
picker just he gonna pick his own
costume I should he did because I was
insistent upon a mummy and he vetoed me
which is why we're in a tie today
fast and furious 9 there's a delay how
are you feeling about it
and is there an update at all um no no
no updates on my end but um you know I
it's it's not it's not that crazy a
delay and I don't know there are there
always other iterations that can come
about so we'll see you know if you're
gonna be in the hub's
spin-off no I don't think so
you